bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de l'infini bah ouais rien que ça alors
l'infini il ya plusieurs manières de
l'envisager suivant comprends le point
de vue du mathématicien du physicien ou
bien du philosophe
dans cette vidéo je vais pas avoir le
temps de parler de tout ça à la fois
donc je me concentrais sur un aspect
particulier qui l infini en
mathématiques et plus précisément les
ensembles infinie
en mathématiques il ya plusieurs
manières d'approcher le concept d'infini
et une des manières les plus
élémentaires c'est celle de la théorie
des ensembles alors en mathématiques
souvent on manipule des ensembles c'est
à dire des collections de trucs et les
trucs on appelle ça des éléments et on
peut faire des ensembles un peu de ce
qu'on veut des ensembles de nombre de
figures géométriques de fonction etc et
une des choses les plus simples dont on
puisse parler à propos d'un ensemble
c'est sa taille c'est à dire le nombre
d'éléments qui contient et on appelle ça
son cardinal par exemple le cardinal de
cet ensemble ces six celui la c4
celui-là 7 et c'est un des tout premiers
ensemble qu'on considère quand on fait
des maths c'est celui des nombres
entiers positif c'est-à-dire 0 1 2 3 4 5
etc
on appelle ça les entiers naturels et on
note grands thèmes comme ça va très vite
c'est quoi le cardinal de l'ensemble des
entiers naturels y en a combien des
entiers naturels
il y en a une infinité et non et ben
ouais et on peut même prendre ça comme
définition l'infini on va dire que
l'infini c'est le cardinal de l'ensemble
des entiers naturels
voilà et on note ça avec ce symbole que
vous connaissez certainement qui
ressemble à un but coucher et qu'on
appelle le lemniscate ok donc on a une
définition de l'infini c'est le cardinal
de grant est alors à voir un peu où ça
nous mène quand on considère un ensemble
il ya cette idée un petit peu intuitif
que si on prend qu'une partie de cet
ensemble sont cardinal il doit être
forcément plus petits en apparaît assez
logique
en voyant ce que ça donne avec les
entiers naturels on va considérer grand
peine donc l'ensemble des entiers
naturels et on va considérer à côté un
autre ensemble
l'ensemble des entiers plus grand que -1
c'est à dire moins 1 0 1 2 3 etc
et cet ensemble on va l'appeler eux on
voyait que eux c'est la même chose que l
on a juste ajouté un élément qui est le
nombre - 1
le cardinal de cet ensemble eux qu'est
ce que c'est intuitivement on sent bien
que c'est l'infini aussi mais en même
temps on sent bien que eux ils quand
même plus grand que n
donc est ce que c'est vraiment le même
infini ou est ce que c'est un a fini
plus gros auquel il faudrait par exemple
donner un autre symbole
en fait ce qui nous manque ici c'est un
moyen de comparer les infinies alors
pour essayer de voir un petit peu plus
clair on peut avoir recours à un petit
jeu qui s'appelle l'hôtel de ville
art l'hôtel de ville berthe c'est une
petite énigme qui a été proposé pour la
première fois par le mathématicien david
gilberte à imaginer qu'on ait un hôtel
qui est une infinité de chambre qui soit
numérotés par les nombres entiers
naturels dont il ya la chance 0
la chambre 1 la chambre de etc et
maintenant supposons que toutes les
chambres sans exception soient pleines
occupé chacune par une personne alors
tout va bien jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un se
pointent à la réception de l'hôtel et
demande s'il n'aurait pas une chambre de
libre
alors là le gérant répond que ba non ya
pas de chambre de libre puisque l'hôtel
est plein et puis là le type qui vient
d'arriver qui en fait l mathématicien
dix meilleurs en fait via une solution
il suffit de dire à chaque personne
présente dans l'hôtel d'aller dans la
chambre suivante celui qui actuellement
arrachant 0 on va dans la chambre
1 celui qui est dans la chambre un
valeurs-là 2 etc
et avec ça tout le monde est relogé sauf
que la chambre 0 devient libre et le
type peut s'y installer problème résolu
alors là on vient de faire quelque chose
qui est très intéressant on a pris
l'ensemble des personnes présentes dans
l'hôtel c'est à dire tous ceux qui
étaient déjà là plus le nouveau venu et
on leur a attribué un nouveau numéro de
chambre de sorte que chaque chambre
contiennent exactement une personne et
chaque personne est sa chambre à l'us
c'est à dire qu'on a établi une
correspondance parfaite entre les
personnes présentes et les chambres on
les a à parier en termes techniques
quand on fait ça on appelle ça une bille
gestion et la définition qu'on va
prendre c'est qu'à partir du moment où
on peut faire une pige hexion entre deux
ensembles qu'on peut vraiment à parier
leurs éléments 2 à 2 les deux ensembles
ont le même cardinal est donc là on a
moyen de comparer les tailles dans
semblent infinies il suffit de voir si
on peut faire une pige hexion entre est
donc en particulier si on a un ensemble
et qu'on peut montrer qu'on peut faire
une direction entre cet ensemble et puis
l'ensemble trentaine des entiers
naturels
ça veut dire qu'ils ont le même cardinal
l'infini celui qu'on a déjà vu et qu'on
a noté avec le lemniscate à faire une
injection avec grant n1 l'ensemble des
entiers naturels c'est un bien grand mot
pour dire numérotées si vous avez un
ensemble et que vous pouvez numérotée
ces éléments alors vous pouvez créer une
direction entre cet ensemble et grant n
est donc cet ensemble il aura le même
cardinal que grands thèmes et ça ça
permet de répondre à notre question de
tout à l'heure à notre ensemble eux on
peut le numérotés et donc le cardinal 2
bah c'est le même que celui de haine
c'est bien l'infini le même un fond et
du coup vous voyez qu avec ce concept
d'infini il se passe un truc bizarre en
général quand on prend un ensemble et
qu'on considère seulement une
sous-partie que cet ensemble sont
cardinal est plus petit et voilà c'est
pas le cas l'ensemble grant n
il est strictement inclus dans
l'ensemble eux et pourtant ils ont le
même cardinal cette situation c'est une
des caractéristiques et même des
définitions possibles d ensemble un film
est bien sûr on peut étendre plus loin
le petit jeu de l'hôtel de l'illberg si
jamais il n'y a pas une personne qui se
pointent à la réception mais à 42
personnes
ben c'est facile il suffit de décaler de
42 chambres et le tour est joué
maintenant ce qu'on peut se demander
c'est qu'est ce qui se passe s'ils
arrivent à la réception un bus contenant
une infinité de personnes eh ben on peut
quand même s'en sortir pour reloger tout
le monde vous voyez comment mais pour ça
il suffit de dire à ceux qui sont déjà
dans l'hôtel de prendre la chambre dont
le numéro est le double de leur chambre
actuel est donc celui qui est dans la
chance 0 reste en lâchant 2 0 celui qui
est dans la une va dans la 2 celui qui
est dans la deux valeurs l'a4 et c est
du coup toutes les chambres
un père sont libres pour les nouveaux
arrivants et on vide le bus en
remplissant l'hôtel ce qu'on a fait là à
nouveau c'est une direction puisqu'on a
pris l'ensemble des personnes présentes
à toutes celles qui sont dans l'hôtel et
toutes celles qui sont dans le bus et on
leur a filé un nouveau numéro de chambre
donc on a établi une déjection entre
l'ensemble des personnes présentes et
l'ensemble grands tels des entiers
naturels et donc ça montre bien que
l'ensemble des personnes présentes
il a un cardinal qui est aussi l'infini
le cardinal de grand âge
mathématiquement ce qu'on a fait là ses
équivalents à montrer que si on
considère l'ensemble des entiers positif
ou négatif ce qu'on appelle l'ensemble
des antilles est relatif
vous savez on le note z parfois et
basson cardinal est le même que n
puisqu'on peut numéroter les entiers
relatif comme ça par exemple et vous
voyez que comme tourner aux personnes
les numéros pairs sont attribués au
nombre positif et les numéros impairs
sont attribués aux nombres négatifs avec
ce petit jeune numérotation on a montré
qu'il y avait autant dentier relatif que
dentier naturel ce qui est assez bizarre
mais dans le même genre on peut aussi
montrer qu'il ya autant de nombreux
pères que d'anti naturelles autant de
nombre qui sont des carrés et c'est tout
c'est ensemble qu'ils ont le même
cardinal que haine parce qu'on arrive à
les numéroter on dit
ils sont dénombrable évidemment ce qu'on
a envie de se demander s'il n'existerait
pas des ensembles infini qui soit
vraiment plus gros que celui des entiers
naturels d ensemble qu'on n'arriverait
pas à numéroter donc qui ne serait pas
dénombrable pour essayer de répondre à
cette question on peut retourner dans
l'hôtel de ville verte
bien donc on a vu que l'hôtel de ville
berthe même s'il était déjà plein et que
se pointe et un bus infinie rempli de
personnes on arrivait quand même à
recaser tout le monde donc pour
fabriquer un ensemble infini qui soit
vraiment plus gros que l'ensemble des
entiers naturels
il va falloir y aller un petit peu plus
fort la reprenons l'hôtel et imaginons
cette fois que c'est pas un bus infini
qui arrivent mais une infinité de bus
qui contiennent chacun une infinité de
personnes alors comment on fait alors là
vous dit peut-être que le gérant est
coincé et que cette fois ça fait
vraiment beaucoup trop de monde pour
reloger dans l'hôtel de ville verte
et ben non on va voir une manière de
s'en sortir est en fait y en a plusieurs
apprenez toutes les personnes qui sont
initialement dans l'hôtel et reloger les
uniquement dans les chambres qui sont
des nombres premiers
donc la première personne vous la mettez
dans la chambre numéro 2 la deuxième
dans la 3 puis ensuite dans la 5 dans la
cet dans la honte dans la 13 etc
il ya une infinité de nombreux premiers
donc il ya aucun problème pour reloger
tout le monde ensuite vous prenez le bus
numéro i et vous prenez la personne
assise à la place numéro j et vous la
mettez dans la chambre depuis 106 x 3 ^
par exemple si vous prenez le deuxième
bulls et la première place à la personne
qui est là vous la mettez dans la
chambre numéro 12
et vous voyez que c'est pas un nombre
premier donc cette chambre elle est
forcément livres et vous pouvez vous
convaincre qu'avec cette numérotation on
peut pas avoir deux personnes qui se
retrouvent dans la même chambre et on
peut reloger tout le monde est comme ça
non seulement on a réussi à caser tout
le monde non plus il reste plein de
place libre à vous pouvez vous
convaincre par exemple que la chambre
numéro 10 où la chambre numéro 14
c'est bien à la fin elles sont toujours
libres alors mathématiquement qu'est ce
que ça veut dire que cette nouvelle
version du problème de l'hôtel de ville
verte
alors quand tout le monde débarque à
l'hôtel les personnels sont définis par
une paire dentier
le premier c'est le numéro du bus et le
deuxième c'est le numéro de la place où
elles sont assis donc il ya autant de
personnes présentes que de perdre entier
possible ou une autre manière de le lire
il y en a autant que deux cases sur un
damier infinie
cet ensemble là on l'appelle n au carré
ou parfois n 2 est donc ce qu'on vient
de faire en résolvant ce problème de
l'hôtel s'est montré que l'ensemble n 2
il est dénombrable il a le même cardinal
que
ce qui est quand même un peu contre
intuitif parce qu'on a vraiment
l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup plus de
cases que dentier naturel et pourtant si
vous n'êtes pas convaincu je vous montre
une deuxième manière de numéroter cet
ensemble
alors regardez on may 6 0 puis 1 2 et 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 et c est comme ça on peut
établir une déjection entre grands
thèmes et n 2 donc est ce qui se passe
si on va encore plus loin imaginons
qu'on ait une infinité bateau qui
débarque qui contiennent chacun une
infinité de bus dans lesquels il ya une
infinité de personnes qui sont assises
eh ben on peut quand même s'en sortir je
vous laisse trouver comment et
d'ailleurs ça marche aussi avec une
infinité de vaisseaux spatiaux qui vous
débarquerait une infinité de bateaux
contenant une affinité bus etc tout ça
c'est quand même un peu décourageant
visiblement chaque fois qu'on essaye de
construire un ensemble qui serait
vraiment plus gros que l'ensemble des
entiers naturels
il semble que ça rate on fabrique que
des ensembles qui en fait sont
dénombrable c'est-à-dire sont obligés
ctions avec l'ensemble des entiers
naturels
alors pour essayer de fabriquer un
ensemble qui serait vraiment plus gros
il nous faut un ensemble qu'ils soient
pas des nombres à c'est à dire un
ensemble qu'on ne puisse pas numérotées
et bien ensemble comme ça il y en a un
qu'on connaît c'est l'ensemble des
nombres réels
intuitivement on sent bien qu'il ya
beaucoup plus de nombreux rem que
nombres entiers parce que les réels ils
forment un continuum alors que les
entiers d'accès quelque chose de
discontinues sauf que ça sait
intuitivement et jusqu'ici on a vu que
notre intuition et nous a pas
franchement aidé alors est ce que c'est
vraiment possible de démontrer
rigoureusement qui a plus de réel que
dentier et ben oui on peut alors la
démonstration je vais pas vous la donner
dans le détail mais pas très compliqué
elle est due à un mathématicien qui a
beaucoup travaillé sur l'infini qui
s'appelle georges kantor le principe de
la démonstration c'est que c'est une
démonstration par l'absurde on suppose
qu'on peut numérotée l'ensemble des
nombres réels et on montre que dans ce
cas là on arrive toujours à construire
un nombre réel qui n'était pas dans
notre numérotation de départ donc on a
une contradiction et ça montre qu en
fait l'ensemble des nombres réels
il est pas dénombrable et donc la
conclusion de kantar c'est que le
cardinal des nombres réels
bah c'est aussi l'infini mais c'est un
infini qui est vraiment strictement plus
gros que celui dont on a parlé jusqu'ici
c'est un infini indénombrables alors du
coup ce qu'on peut faire c'est le noter
différemment maintenant on va choisir
omega alors maintenant évidemment il se
passe avec les nombres réels le même
genre de bizarreries qui se passait déjà
avec les nombres entiers naturels
considérer tous les nombres réels qui
sont strictement compris entre 0 et 1
intuitivement toujours on a envie de
penser qu'il ya moins de nombres réels
entre 0 et 1 que de nombres réels au
total et ben non il y en a en quelque
sorte autant pour le montrer il suffit
de trouver une direction entre cet
ensemble et l'ensemble des normes réel
voilà par exemple bas je vous en donne
une cette fonction elle envoie tous les
nombres réels qui sont compris entre 0
et 1 sur l'ensemble moins l'infini plus
infinie et réciproquement est donc cet
ensemble et l'ensemble des nombres réels
ils ont le même cardinal omega autre
paradoxe apparent on a envie de penser
qu'il ya beaucoup plus de points dans un
carré que dans un segment
et ben non encore raté on peut montrer
qu'il ya une déjection entre les deux
avec l'astuce suivante considérer un
point xy dans le carré dont x et y sont
tous les deux compris entre 0 et des
composés chacun des nombres en écriture
décimales est fabriqué le point z sur le
segment 0-1 en alternant les décimales
2x et de y
donc à chaque point du quart et
correspond un unique point du segment et
réciproquement
donc ces deux ensembles ont le même
cardinal qui est aussi omega alors si on
se croisait un petit peu la tête on
pourrait aller encore plus loin et
fabriqué vraiment un ensemble dont le
cardinal serait vraiment plus grand que
omega
mais il ya une autre question qui est
assez intéressante c'est de se demander
si il existe des ensembles infini qui
sont en quelque sorte plus gros que les
anti naturel mais plus petit que les
nombres réels c'est à dire qu'il
faudrait trouver un ensemble dont le
cardinal soit plus grand que celui de
haine mais plus petit que celui de m une
sorte d'infini intermédiaire entre les
deux les 72 heures la kantor pensait que
en fait j'en avais pas mais il savait
pas le démontrer alors il a appelé cette
idée l'hypothèse du continu dans
l'hypothèse du continue il ya un certain
nombre de mathématiciens au cours du 20e
siècle qui ont essayé de la démontrer ou
alors de trouver un contre-exemple sa
terre de fabriquer un ensemble qui soit
plus grand que les nombres entiers mais
plus petit que le nombre réel est en
fait c'est pas simple intuitivement on
pourrait penser à l'ensemble des nombres
rationnelle vous savez les fractions on
sent bien que des fractions en a quand
même beaucoup plus que de nombres
entiers mais moins que de nom réel
c'est un truc un peu intermédiaire et
ben non en fait une traction ckoi
basséen numérateur et un dénominateur
donc l'ensemble des fractions c'est en
gros l'ensemble des
haarde entier donc c'est n 2 et n 2 on a
vu qu'il est dénombrable donc l'ensemble
des fractions il est pas plus gros que
l'ensemble des entiers naturels
à l'heure qu'il est on pourrait toujours
être en train de s'escrimer à essayer de
trancher la question de l'hypothèse du
continu sauf qu'au milieu du xxème
siècle il a été démontré que cette
question elle est indécidable vous a
peut-être déjà entendu parler de cette
idée et du théorème de gödel qui dit que
en mathématiques à partir d'un certain
niveau de complexité
il existe forcément des propositions
qu'on ne peut ni démontrer ni infirmé et
bien l'hypothèse du continu c'en est une
c'est une question qu'on ne peut pas
trancher ou plutôt dont la réponse
dépend du système d'action qu'on utilise
alors si pour vous tout ça c'est du
chinois rassurez vous je vais m'arrêter
là
mais je vous promets un jour je vous
reparlerai du théorème de gödel merci
d'avoir suivi cette vidéo si elle vous a
plu n'hésitez pas à la partager pour
m'aider à faire connaître la chaîne si
le problème de gilberte vous amusez vous
pouvez aller voir la vidéo de l ggyc
traite de ce sujet vous pouvez me
retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux
facebook twitter
ceux qui le souhaitent peuvent le
soutenir sur tipi merci beaucoup à tous
les types heures et vous pouvez aussi
aller lire mon blog qui s'appelle
science étonnante
merci et à bientôt